THE BIDEN AGENDA.
BREAKING NEWS ON HOW TO PAY FOR
THE BIDEN AGENDA TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC.
THE TOP TWO DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS ALONG WITH THE BIDEN
TREASURY SECRETARY STANDING
TOGETHER LAST HOUR TO ANNOUNCE
THEY HAVE A FRAMEWORK TO PAY FOR
A MASSIVE DEMOCRATIC SPENDING
PACKAGE THAT COVERS ISSUES
RANGING FROM CHILD CARE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HEALTH CARE POLICY.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE, THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE HAVE REACHED
AGREEMENT ON A FRAMEWORK THAT
WILL PAY FOR ANY FINAL
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT, SO THE
REVENUE SIDE OF THIS WE HAVE AN
AGREEMENT ON, OKAY?
THANK YOU.
THE FRAMEWORK, AN AGREEMENT OF A
FRAMEWORK.
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE A BIG DEAL,
RIGHT?
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF MISSING
PIECES.
NO SPECIFICS YET, FOR EXAMPLE,
ON JUST WHAT TAX HIKE DEMOCRATS
HAVE AGREED TO SUPPORT AND EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT, NO AGREEMENT YET
ON HOW MUCH MONEY DEMOCRATS NEED
TO RAISE MEANING NO AGREEMENT
YET ON THE FINAL PRICE TAG FOR
THAT BIG DEMOCRATIC PLAN.
LET'S GET STRAIGHT UP TO OUR
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MANU RAJU.
MANU, THEY MAKE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT OUT TO BE A BIG
DEAL, BUT A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
>> Reporter: THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND NOT A LOT OF
CLARITY.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
MEMBERS HAVE NOT SIGNED OFF ON
THIS IN THE RANK AND FILE.
EVEN SOME OF THE KEY CHAIRMEN OF
THE COMMITTEES ARE STILL IN THE
DARK ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY THIS
MEANS AND WHAT THIS MEANS IS AN
AGREEMENT ABOUT SOME OF THE
OPTIONS THAT THEY COULD DO TO
PAY FOR THIS MASSIVE PLAN, AND
THIS AGREEMENT WAS REACHED BY
THIS OPTIONS TO PAY FOR THE PLAN
AMONG THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS,
NANCY PELOSI, CHUCK SCHUMER YOU
SAW THERE AS WELL AS THE KEY
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEES WHO
ARE IN CHARGE OF TAX WRITING,
RON WIDEN ON THE HOUSE SIDE AND
RICHIE NEIL ON THE HOUSE SIDE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION ITSELF.
WHAT THEY DON'T HAVE IS AN
AGREEMENT AMONG THE MODERATE
DEMOCRATS WHO NEED TO PROVIDE
THE VOTES FOR THIS MASSIVE
EXPANSION OF THE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET.
THEY DON'T HAVE AN AGREEMENT
AMONG OF THE PROGRESSIVES AND
THOSE DISCUSSIONS WILL CONTINUE
ABOUT EVERYTHING ABOUT WHAT'S IN
HERE, THE DETAILS AND THE PRICE
TAG.
NOW, LATER TODAY MODERATE
DEMOCRATS ARE MEETING WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS WHO ARE
COMING TO CAPITOL HILL TO TALK
ABOUT THE FINANCING OPTIONS AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN GET
BEHIND IT.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE'S NO
AGREEMENT AMONG SOME OF THE KEY
MEMBERS.
JOHN, I TRIED TO PRESS SPEAKER
PELOSI AT THE PRESS CONFERENCE
WHAT THIS AGREEMENT IMMEDIATE
AND SHE MADE IT CLEAR THEY STILL
DON'T HAVE AN AGREEMENT ON THE
PRICE TAG.
>> THIS IS NOT THE PRICE TAG.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT'S IN THE
BILL, WHAT'S IN THE BILL FOR
CHILDREN, WHAT'S IN THE BILL.
IT'S NOT ABOUT A PRICE TAG OR
ANYTHING.
IT'S ABOUT VALUES, NOT DOLLARS.
>> WELL, THE PRICE TAG, IS OF
COURSE, SIGNIFICANT HERE BECAUSE
WHAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
INITIALLY WAS $3.5 TRILLION
PLAN, JUST A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF INVESTMENT IN ALL ASPECTS OF
THE ECONOMY, RAISING TAXES ON
CORPORATIONS AND WEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS, BUT MODERATES LIKE
JOE MANCHIN AND OTHERS WANT THAT
PRICE TAG LESS THAN $2 TRILLION.
PROGRESSIVES WANT MORE THAN $3
TRILLION, AND THAT MEANS THERE'S
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF DEBATE
THAT STILL HAS TO BE HAD AND,
JOHN, THIS IS ALL TIED TO THAT
KEY VOTE THAT IS HAPPENING ON
MONDAY OVER THAT SEPARATE
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE THAT
PASSED THE SENATE LAST MONTH.
PELOSI IS NOT SAYING
SPECIFICALLY SHE WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE VOTE ON MONDAY
BUT THAT'S ALSO SPECIFIC BECAUSE
THE PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS IN HER
CAUCUSES ARE THREATENING TO VOTE
AGAINST THAT PLAN AND SINK THAT
PLAN IF THAT LARGER DEAL IS NOT
AGREED TO.
SO MUCH WORK HAS TO BE DONE AND
A LOT OF QUESTIONS, STILL, JOHN?
>> MORE QUESTIONS.
MORE QUESTIONS I THINK NOW THAN
BEFORE THEY ANNOUNCED THIS QUOTE
UNQUOTE FRAMEWORK.
MANU RAJU, HAPPEN ATE THE HUSTLE
ON CAPITOL HILL.
WITH US IN STUDIO TO SHARE THEIR
REPORTING, CNN'S KASIE HUNT,
JEFF MACE OP OF REUTERS AND
CLAUDIA GRISALES AND MELANIE
ZANONES AND I'M GOING BACK TO A
QUESTION ASKED OF GARY HART
YEARS AGO, WHERE'S THE BEEF?
ALL THE DEMOCRATS COME OUT HAPPY
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS NOW TAKING
THE POINT ON THIS.
YES, A LOT TO BE RESOLVED.
SOMEHOW THE DEMOCRATS FEEL THE
NEED TO CLAIM MOMENTUM TODAY SO
THEY SAY THEY HAVE THIS
FRAMEWORK BUT YOU RIP BACK THE
CURTAIN, WHAT?
>> IS IT -- I DON'T KNOW IF THE
WIZARD IS IN THERE OR NOT.
NO.
IT'S REMARKABLE TO ME THAT
SCHUMER WENT IN THIS.
HOW HE WALKED UP TO THIS PODIUM,
DELIVERS WHAT IS CLEARLY
DESIGNED TO BE A HEADLINE
INDICATING THEY ARE MAKING SOME
SORT OF PROGRESS AND NANCY
PELOSI HAS TO STEP IN THERE AND
ESSENTIALLY SAY JUST TRY US,
THERE'S SOME THERE THERE BUT I'M
NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU ANY
FURTHER DETAILS AND SHE WAS
PRETTY CLOSE TO FLASHING SOME
FRUSTRATION THERE BUT DID MANAGE
TO REIN IT IN.
BIG PICTURE IT REALLY STRUCK ME
THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO PROJECT
A MESSAGE OF CALM.
I MEAN, THEY HAVE NOT HAD A
GREAT COUPLE OF DAYS IN TERMS OF
HOW THE PUBLIC IS LOOKING AT
WHAT THEY ARE DOING HERE.
>> BUT THEY HAD A BETTER DAY
YESTERDAY.
AGAIN, PROGRESSIVES COME OUT
MEATING WITH THE PRESIDENT
SAYING IT WAS HELPFUL AND
MODERATES COME OUT AFTER THE
MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
SAY IT'S HELPFUL.
THEY HAVE A FRAMEWORK, BERNIE
SANDERS, THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE WHICH
MAKES HIM NORTHERN WHEN IT COMES
TO MATTERS OF BIG SPENDING PLANS
AND CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
HE'S LIKELY TONIGHT BRIDGE TO
THE HOUSE PROGRESSIVES IF THEY
WILL HAVE A SMALLER PACKAGE THAN
3.5 TRILLION.
BERNIE SANDERS SAYS I HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT HIS LEADER CHUCK
SCHUMER JUST ANNOUNCED.
>> WE SHOULD BE VERY SKEPTICAL
WHAT DEMOCRATIC LEADERS ARE
TELLING US TODAY BECAUSE THEY
ARE UNDER SO MUCH PRESSURE RIGHT
NOW THEIR PROGRESSIVE WING THAT
THEY ARE MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
THIS MASSIVE ECONOMIC
RECONCILIATION PACK AND AND UBER
IS THEY ARE STILL HAVING A
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE VOTE
NEXT WEEK AND PROGRESSIVES HAVE
SAID WE WON'T VOTE FOR IT UNLESS
WE SEAT RECONCILIATION BILL
PASSED.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN NEXT
WEEK SO WHAT LEADERS ARE TRYING
TO DO IS MAKE SOME SORT OF
PROGRESS.
THEY HOPE THAT THERE CAN BE A
FRAME WERK AND THEY CAN COME UP
WITH A GENERAL FRAMEWORK, ENOUGH
TO REACH PROGRESSIVES.
THEY HAVE SO MUCH THEY STILL
NEED TO RESOLVE AND EVEN IF
MODERATES CAN COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE WILLING
TO PUT FORWARD, IT MIGHT NOT BE
ENOUGH TO MOVE MODERATES.
>> WE ESEAL IF THERE'S MORE TO
IT THAN JUST AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAY OUR KEY
COMMITTEE CHAIRS HAVE AN
AGREEMENT ONCE THEY GET A FINAL
NUMBER THEY WILL FIGURE IT OUT
AND THEN THEY NEED TO GET A
FINAL NUMBER AND FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DIVVY IT UP.
FREE PRE-"K," FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, CHILD CARE CREDITS AND
TAX CREDITS AND PROGRESSIVES
SAID IT WAS NICE TO MEET WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THEY ALSO COME
OUT SAYING WE WANT 3.5.
WE WERE TOLD.
ALREADY COMPROMISED FROM 6 TO
3.5.
THIS IS THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS.
>> THIS VERY SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE ARE NOT REPRESENTATIVE
OF, YOU KNOW, REALLY MODERATE
DEMOCRATS IN THE TOUGHEST
DISTRICT.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE TO SAY -- I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN SAY THAT THE
MODERATES ARE AGAINST THIS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
>> JEFF, FROM A WHITE HOUSE
PERSPECTIVE, THE PRESIDENT HAS
NOT SAID THIS IS MY FINAL NUMBER
BUT HE DID ASK THE MODERATES
YESTERDAY TO GIVE HIM A NUMBER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HE WANTS A NUMBER FROM THE
MODERATES.
IS THAT NOT ESSENTIALLY THE
PRESIDENT SAYING IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE $3.5 TRILLION BECAUSE IF
IT WAS GOING TO BE 3.5 HE WOULD
BE LEANING ON THE MODERATES TO
SUPPORT IT.
INSTEAD HE SAID YOU NEED TO MAKE
YOUR COMPROMISE AND MAKE IT NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE'S A RECOGNITION AT THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT THE 3.5 WON'T
BE THE END GAME.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS IT, AND
SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS THIS IS
ABOUT PRIORITIES AND IT'S ABOUT
POLICY AND HAVING SPECIFIC
THINGS IN THE BILL, AND THAT'S
WHAT MATTERS, BUT ALL OF THOSE
PRIORITIES HAVE TO HAVE A PRICE
TAG ATTACHED TO THEM AND WHEN
YOU TAKE ONE OUT YOU'LL SUBTRACT
SOME MONEY FROM THAT OVERALL
BALL AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
HAVEN'T CLAIREIFIED AND
OBVIOUSLY THE WHITE HOUSE HASN'T
CLARIFIED IT EARED.
THEY HAVEN'T SPECIFICALLY SAID
THIS IS OUR REDLINE ON A
SPECIFIC POLICY OR NUMBER.
THEY WANT TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE NEGOTIATION.
>> AND THE PROGRESSIVES WANT THE
TWO TRAINS ON PARALLEL TRACKS
WHICH IS TO VOTE MONDAY ON THE
ALREADY -- ALREADY PASSED THE
SENATE, THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND THEY
WANT THE 3.5 OR 2.8 OR 2.
THEY WANT THE RECONCILIATION
PACKAGE ON THE SAME TRACK.
THE RECONCILIATION PACKAGE WILL
NOT BE READY BY MONDAY.
THAT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR TO
EVERYBODY AND THE MODERATES SAY
THE SPEAKER PROMISED THEM A
VOTE.
IS THERE A MIDDLE GROUND?
IS THERE A WAY OUT?
IS THE ONLY WAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO CALL THESE
MODERATES AND SAY, SORRY, WE
NEED TO DELAY THE VOTE A WEEK OR
TWO?
>> IT SEEMS THAT'S WHERE THAT
WAS HEADING.
PELOSI WAS SOFTENING HER STANCE
ON WHETHER MOUND IS THE VOTE FOR
THIS BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE.
WE HEARD FROM PROGRESSIVES WHO
LEFT THE MEETING YESTERDAY WHO
SAID, YOU KNOW, THAT SEPTEMBER
27th DATE IS AN ARBITRARY DATE
SO THEY CAN MOVE THAT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MOVE THE GOAL
POSTS AND WHETHER EVERYBODY
COMES ALONG, WHETHER THIS WRECKS
THEIR PLANS WITH BOTH BILLS
REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> I WENT WAY BACK AT THE
BEGINNING QUOTING WALTER MONDALE
AND LET ME COME CLOSER TO THE
MODERN DAYS, JOHN POET STA, YOU
KNOW, WORKED IN THE BILL CLINTON
WHITE HOUSE AND WAS AROUND IN
THE OBAMA DAYS AS WELL.
HE SAYS THIS TO DEMOCRATS IN A
MEMO.
HISTORICAL TRENDS MAKE IT CLEAR
DEMOCRATS WILL FACE SEVERE
HEATWINDS NEXT NOVEMBER BUT
NOTHING WILL GUARANTEE A
POLITICAL RECKONING FASTER THAN
IF THE DEMOCRATS FAIL TO PASS
ANYTHING.
THAT THE PRESIDENT'S MAIN GOAL
YESTERDAY.
GET THAT ACROSS TO THE MOST
LIBERAL AND THE MOST MODERATE
DEMOCRATS THAT IN THE END YOU
HAVE TO COME TOGETHER OR WE ALL
SINK.
SUCCESS, FAILURE OR TBD.
>> EXACTLY.
THE REALITY FOR DEMOCRATS, WE'VE
BEEN SAYING THIS ALL SUMMER, THE
ONLY THING WE CAN'T DO IS
NOTHING, RIGHT?
THE DETAILS HARDLY MATTER IN
MANY CASES, SO THE CHALLENGE
THAT -- I THINK FOR PROGRESSIVES
SHEER THIS IS THE SHOP THAT THEY
HAVE.
THEY HAVE FROM NOW UNTIL
PROBABLY DECEMBER BEFORE WE'RE
HITTING MID-TERM ELECTION SEASON
AND THEY LIKELY LOSE THE HOUSE,
THAT'S IT.
SO THEY CLEARLY WILL TRYING TO
EXERCISE THEIR LEVERAGE AND HOLD
OUT THESE THREATS AROUND THE
BIPARTISAN BILL, BUT REALITY IS
AT SOME POINT THEY WILL HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT WHETHER
THEY ARE REALLY PREPARED TO DO
NO, AND I THINK HISTORY SHOWS US
THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT
NECESSARILY TAKEN THAT TACK,
UNLIKE FRANKLY THE KAMIKAZE
FOLKS IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WHO THE TEA PARTY WERE WILLING
TO DO SOME OF THESE THINGS.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE THAT, BUT, AGAIN, IT'S
STILL REALLY HARD TO SEE HOW WE
GET THERE, AND, YOU KNOW, TO
WHAT JEFF WAS SAYING,
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS